in today's presentation i'll be using
python and selenium in order to solve
wordle
and there are a few different versions
of the wordle website so if anyone is
not familiar with wordle
it pretty much
looks like this
you get to guess letters and figure out
what the correct word is and if you get
a yellow letter it means that the letter
is not in the correct place and if you
uh get a green letter it means that uh
it is in the correct place so i'm gonna
start a screen share so that you can uh
start seeing everything that i see
uh this is what wordle looks like
you have
yellow letters
and you have green letters and you have
to guess
the correct word
and it gives you hints by telling you
what letters are in the correct place
and which letters are in the incorrect
place
so we can use automation to solve wordle
so if we do
pi test wordle test dot py
it's going to run a python program that
guesses wordle for you
so it's going to load up the page with
selenium and then it's going to start
guessing words and it's going to take
the hints that it has there and try to
figure out
the correct word
so here it's now on the fourth try
and there you have it it solved it in
five tries bluff
so if you're wondering what that script
looks like
this is the word all test
it's some simple python but essentially
it's going to open up the new york times
website
which has the wordle game
and then it's going to
initialize the word list which basically
uh
searches through
a pre-existing list of words so that you
can see
so that it can generate a full list from
that and use that to make guesses
now the full wordle list does not
include all possible five letter words
they basically prune the list in order
to
make it so that maybe bad five letter
words don't show up as possible
solutions that way it's still you know
um
friendly kid friendly et cetera
so uh if anyone is wondering how that
script works there
is a python web automation framework
that i created called selenium base
that essentially allows you to
work with shadow dom more easily click
elements it automatically waits for page
elements to fully load
before interacting with them so that you
don't need additional sleeps or weights
in the code
this selenium base is available on
github it's open source so you can see
all the code if you're interested
particular examples that we run are
found in the selenium-based examples
folder
and there's hundreds of different
examples
and in particular here the ones that we
are going for are the wordle test
and basically it goes through
it uses the algorithm to determine
whether or not the yellow letter is
there or a green letter so that it can
guess the correct word based on the
hints that it had
i'll run it one more time just so that
you can see it in action
yeah the selenium-based tests run with
pi test so i can do pi test wordle test
dot py
and it'll automatically
spin up the web browser and start
playing wordle
so you can see here
it's guessing letters
and
here we go once again it guessed it in
five tries but every time it runs it
runs a little bit differently because
it's using a randomized algorithm
now in the
about a month ago
the website had a full redesign and they
got rid of all their shadow dom elements
which basically is a page within the
page
so in order to show you how it looked on
the original site we can use the web
archive in order to
see
the original wordle page before they
changed it so if we do pi test
wordle archive test.py
it's going to open up
the web archive which is basically a
copy of all past websites
so that you can see
how the wordle game did
in previous renditions
so
this is it's going to be a different
word than you saw before because it's
using an existing version of the website
that was there previously
so a guest ample
in three tries there
and if you're wondering exactly how
the
that website looks underneath
we're going to open it
with the web archive so that you can see
the shadow dom that's there so i'm going
to right click
and inspect the element
which basically allows you to see the
html source for the page
and inside if you can see clearly here
i'm going to
expand it so that you can see a little
more clearly
inside
this website there are these shadow root
elements
and shadow root and is basically
the shadow document
object model which basically has a
website inside a website and interacting
with these
shadow elements
in order to do that you need selenium
four
and you need
the latest version of chrome or chromium
browser
and
from there you're able to
interact with the shadow dom elements in
order to
click the buttons
and pretty much interact with the page
now the shadow roots definitely
complicate
uh the interaction with a web page
because you have to
specifically jump into the shadow root
before interacting with it so if you
wanted to say
click a specific button
i'm just going to exit out of there you
need to basically
interact
using the shadow root
because you'll switch in
and then you'll click inside so if we
were to go into the script that
interacts with the shadow dom
we have here the test wordle archive
test
you'll see that it uses a special syntax
such as here
to interact with the shadow dom elements
more easily
than you would if you were going to
directly use a selenium command to do
that
so it uses the colon colon shadow
selector
it's basically a unique selector to
selenium base but essentially it'll go
to this selector it will jump into
the shadow root
that is there
and then it will look inside for another
element
and then it will let you jump inside the
shadow root again so that you can click
the game icon
for instance here this lets you
close the initial screen that pops up
whenever you go to wordle for the first
time
so this is interacting with shadow root
elements
using wordle
so now that we have that
uh let's jump back into
uh the example that we have here so
essentially if you weren't using
selenium base
to get to the shadow root
you'd need to use a command such as this
to click it and it gets much longer
because you have to individually pierce
the shadow root elements
so first you could do something with
python driver.find element by css
selector the game app
and then you could do dot shadow root
and dot shadow root will then
take you inside the first level shadow
root and then from there you'd have to
find another element inside of it
and then keep going through the shadow
root so that it becomes
a significantly long line however with
selenium base it simplifies the
interaction with shadow root so that
this giant line here
can be done entirely with just a self
dot click line
uh self dot click game app
and then it pierces through the shadow
root and lets you basically
interact
i'm going to run that test again so that
you can see it interacting with
particular shadow roots from the wordle
archive website
so it's loading in now and this is the
version that has the shadow root
and it's picking a random uh
wordle
from the past
these are some terrible words here that
it's guessing
let's see
guess that in three tries
i'll run it again just so that you can
see that it's going to pick a completely
uh
random version of wordle from the past
and every time it runs it's going to
guess different words in order to get to
the final word
and let's see
try number four
shall okay so here the word was shall
and it took four different tries to
guess that
so
if you're wondering
how to run any of these example scripts
that you see here
all that is accessible
from the
selenium-based website where you'll find
examples like this
and many others
so let's see the one that we just ran
here
with the shadow root
that is the wordle archive test
and i'll just walk through
how the whole script works
so
first uh it's going to generate
a random
uh wordle from the past using the
existing format that is set up for it so
if you look inside
this page here
you'll see that it uses the web archive
which basically
allows you to see
a past version of a website if say a
website later changes you can go back to
a very specific date so here 2022
uh this one was april 17th
and it had a time stamp from that day
and it used
the wordle website so it basically went
through
and found the past wordle
in order to get to that so i generate a
url that looks like this
from here so that i can get to
the past wordle
version
and then i initialize the word list
and then i basically pick a random word
so i do word equals random dot choice
self.word list
in python this random dot choice
essentially
lets me pick a random item from a list
of words
and the self.word list i already
pre-calc
pre-calculated uh at the beginning which
basically
has all possible five-letter words that
will be available when you're guessing
wordle so
random.choice gave me a random word
and when i started guessing i basically
mapped out the various letters inside
wordle so that i can click the buttons
and after i go through a round of
guesses
i basically
um
try to calculate
what
letters are yellow and what letters are
green because that will tell me
uh
whether or not i've guessed a correct
letter or a letter is not in the correct
place
and it goes through this algorithm at
the top here where i modify the word
list where essentially
based on the hints that it gives me i
prune out words that are no longer
possible because the letter isn't there
or uh
it's not in the right place etc and
therefore
i keep shortening the list of guesses
that i have
until eventually
i keep uh clicking through
and there are no other guesses that i
can do and i'll eventually reach the
correct word hopefully in the six
attempts that i have
so i'm going to run
the wordle test on the latest version of
the new york times website
and it's going to run a little faster
because it doesn't have to deal with the
shadow dom because they changed the
website
so here i guess lipid
it saw that the l was not in the correct
place so it's gonna use those hints in
order to try to guess the correct word
and as you can see here
it took those hints
and
we basically
uh solved wordle and you can run it
every time and every time it's going to
run a little different because
it's using
a randomized word generator that
basically will sift through
all the words that are still valid
all right so let's go back to
the main thing so
uh
just want to make sure i'm covering all
the main things that i want to cover in
the presentation
why are we automating wordle well it's
fun to use selenium to play games and
solve puzzles that aren't necessarily
uh around uh test automation because
selenium isn't just for uh automating
testing of websites
it's used
well for
basically automating all sorts of tasks
that
pretty much anything that you want to
automate on the web
anything where there's a web page you
can interact with the elements
and essentially
make anything possible
now that we have wordle running
we can now take the script
and run it inside github actions
so now that we have that let's take a
look at
one of the github actions that i have
running that's actually solving wordle
so you'll see here uh in the md men
selenium-based examples under github you
have github actions and if you click on
say the top one
you'll see that
the script has been running on ubuntu
mac os windows etc
so let's see if we click on one of them
and we jump all the way to the wordle
test
you'll see that the word guest was
bluff
and it got it in five attempts
so this is an example of using github
actions
in order to run wordle and if you're
wondering how exactly to generate the
script for this
uh let's see that
uh github actions file will look like
this for instance for python
pythonpackage.yml and the dot yml file
represents yaml format
which is the format that you'll likely
be using when creating automation
to run in github actions
so
to create that file
you could set it to run on a cron
schedule which is what i did which
basically means it will run at the 30th
minute of every hour
and it will run on the main branch
and
you can specify all the various uh os's
that you want to run on such as ubuntu
20.04
mac os windows etc and the python
versions so right now i'm running that
script on
three seven three eight three nine and
three ten
uh you set up the matrix
uh you'd install dependencies and the
main one is a selenium base which is
part of the requirements file
and you run python setup dot py install
from the git clone
and you'd also install google chrome you
can also install edge and run it there
as well
and once you've uh
installed the drivers and you can do
that with the commands such as sony mace
install chrome driver or sending base
install edge driver
or gecko driver etc those will download
the automatically the
selenium-based web drivers that you need
in order to
interact with the web browsers that
you're spinning up
so from that script
there's multiple different examples here
and the one particular it's the word all
test and i run that at the very end
and in case i can't get it in the six
guesses that it has well it's not a
total guess because
it's using hints so
it's very educated guesses where it
prunes out the words
a command such as dash dash reruns
equals five it's basically a pi test
option
uh which will allow you to rerun a
script if it fails and the case that
wordle because there's a lot of
randomization involved if it's like a
really tough word to guess then i make
sure that there's plenty of room to get
that word
so that when it actually runs
in github actions you can see all right
i want to know
how it's running on the latest version
of windows
and it runs a script
and let's see here it took six attempts
to get bluff
etc
so this is
github actions and it's really easy to
just
work from an existing
dot yaml file in order to set this up
i'm going to go into the chat box and
see if i can answer people's questions
oh can you provide the github repo link
absolutely
so
the github repo link for selenium base
i'm just going to copy that and post
that into the chat
so that
is the link to the main github page
if you're wondering where all these
github actions are running
so that is just
this link
here
i'm going to copy that into there
so
that's the github actions that's
basically
running all those wordle solver tests on
continuous integration
and github actions is one of
many different continuous integration
systems
jenkins is another popular one uh
there's get lab uh here we're using
github actions because it's completely
free for open source projects so if
anyone wants to run
their own workflows on a cron schedule
they can easily do that for free
and if people
aren't sure how to create a new workflow
you can go into action's new workflow
and it'll even show you
how to get started so that you can start
creating
uh your python packages etc
that
you might want in order to
basically
create a whole github actions workflow
for that
and you can use like anaconda there's a
python application
there's a published python package or
just python package which is the simple
one that i use and it helps you get set
up but if you're looking to run
something more advanced
you can use the existing scripts that
i've already created
and if you're wondering just a little
bit more about the github actions for
the selenium-based examples
all that can be found in the uh let's
see i've got an md men's skid up folder
sunny base examples and if you go into
dot github
slash workflows uh this is j the general
location that you'll find
uh your github action scripts
and that's where you'll find your
pythonpackage.yml
file
and you'll immediately get the script
there where you can set the cron
schedule
and you can set how many parallel
tests to run at the same time such as
here
you basically copy paste the script and
then modify it you can easily make
changes so that everything is already
set up and ready to run it automatically
takes care of installing web browsers
for you for your tests
as well as showing you how to structure
uh a test run
and if you're wondering you've probably
been looking and seeing that we're using
pi test
to run all the scripts
and pi test is essentially
a python unit testing framework i know
i'm going a little bit out of order
jumping around like getting the main
examples and going back taking a step
back and saying oh by the way pi test is
used to run
all the scripts that you see here
and it's probably python's most powerful
unit testing framework
it gives you a nice structure
and gives you like output so that you
can see what's going on and you can even
uh generate a fancy report so
let's say i run the script again
and i want to add a few additional
command line options such as dash dash
dashboard and dash dash
html equals report.html
if i run the wordle test now it's going
to
create a dashboard
and a full test report of everything so
that you can see
exactly how
everything looks
as a test report and pi test html
reports uh is a common
pi test feature
so i'm running it again but this time i
use the advanced command line options so
that i can generate
the
report.html file
so if i open that
you'll see that it's generated
basically a dashboard it was one test
that ran and it passed
and you get a nice little pie chart
and it shows you that
it ran the wordle test
and it took a duration of 26.67
seconds
and also shows you useful things such as
in your environment
what your
platform was which was mac os here
uh the pi test version that you had the
different plug-ins that you had so this
right here is pi test html with the
selenium-based dashboard included so
you'll see the pi test html version
and other plugins such as xdist which
lets you run pi test tests
multi-threaded
there are also other plugins that can be
used such as rerun failures which will
let you
re-run
failing tests i'm just going to make it
a little bigger because you probably
can't see it when it's small
re-run failures which lets you rerun a
failing test you can use pi test
ordering to set the order of tests etc
and of course there's selenium base
which is the
pi test plugin that lets you
do browser automation and everything
like that
so
it ran one test and it gave you the
output there
and if you're wondering a little bit
more a more simple example of selenium
base since we jumped right into some of
the most complex tests that you'll have
if we wanted to do a much more simpler
test
such as let's go to
test swag labs
i think they're they are one of the so
swag labs is the sas demo website
it's one of the sponsors of seleniumconf
they have a nice e-commerce website
where you can essentially
log in add an item to a cart and then
check out
so if you're wondering how
selenium-based works there's lots of
simple methods such as type so that you
can type
into
a css selector it which is the default
which makes it easier so you don't have
to specify whether or not it's xpath or
css it'll auto detect
and then it will go through
i'll show you what the website looks
like just so that you can see how sauce
demo works
so
it's a pretty
uh
easy website for
basically doing all sorts of things on
an ecommerce website
it gives you the login information at
the bottom standard user
and then the password for all users is
secret sauce
you log in
you can add an item to a cart
once you've added the item to a cart
should be able to click on the cart
and you'll be able to check out
then you can just type in some fake data
and doesn't really check that
the main idea is that it's a simple
website that you can use for practice
testing and you can see you've added an
item to the shopping cart and you can
click finish
and then it says thank you for your
order
and
you can use selenium-based to
automate that as well just to
take it down from shadow dom
and complex squirtle solving it's more
deterministic because the website is the
same every time it's not like a new
item in like a new list of items every
day so if i run
pi test test
swag labs
and you'll just do a simple test just so
that you can see selenium base handling
all sorts of things so it's going to log
in
it's going to add an item to a cart
it's going to check out
and verify
one of the cool things that you can do
with selenium bass is
slow the test down with demo mode so
that
you can see exactly what the test is
doing as it runs
so if i do
pi test and then the test i want to run
and do dash dash demo
as a pi test command line option
it's basically going to
highlight the various items that are on
the page that it's going to interact
with so you can see that
it's highlighting the fields that's
going to interact with
and whenever there's an assertion it's
going to show at the bottom of the
screen a cert like css selector or here
at the bottom
the inventory item that it's checking
so you can actually see not only
where it's clicking where it's typing
but you can see the assertions that are
being made so that you can say oh if you
add an item to a cart that the text says
remove on the button
instead of add to cart so
it makes it really easy to see
what tests are doing which is very
convenient
and
you can see that demo mode it's just it
slows everything down but it shows you
what your test is doing so that
you can see everything that's going on
so
here it's verifying that you know the
various buttons are there like cancel
and here it's going to
slowly type in
the fields that are there
and you can see
that's verifying all that that it
verifies that the test all the things
t-shirt appeared in the cart
and it's showing all that
that's there
so demo mode is one of many available
command line options that you can use
alongside your selenium-based tests in
order to get
more out of the test
if you're wondering about additional
options so let's just go over to the
main github page
you can see
the pi test options for selenium base
you can easily change the browser so as
you saw before chrome is the default
browser if you don't specify it you can
change the browser so that it runs with
edge firefox even safari
uh let's see you can multi-thread the
tests by using dash n4
and this is using some built-in pi test
multi-threading so if you have a lot of
tests that you need to run
at the same time
pi test multi-threading is the way to do
that
what you saw earlier was the dashboard
with the html report that i showed about
15 10 minutes ago that basically can
give you a full report of all your tests
after it finishes running
there are lots of ways to debug tests
such as using the dash dash pdb option
which means that if a test happens to
fail
it will pause and then
give you a debugger so that you can do
live debugging right then
this will let you rerun failing tests if
you want to do that
uh there's a recorder option so that it
can
record tests and i don't know if i'll
have time to show you that but
the key thing here is if you want to use
one of these selenium servers from our
sponsors such as browser stacks slabs
lambda tests etc
you can run any of your pi test tests
uh on one of their selenium grids by
specifying
the grid server
the key
and the ip address and maybe the port
that you'll need it could be eighty
maybe sometimes it's four four four four
and if there's authentication that is in
the key now essentially let you run
your tests on browser stack sas labs
lambda test etc
and utilize all of their advanced
features
uh there's also selenium-based mobile
mode which will kick off chromium's
mobile device emulator so that if you
have a test that has a mobile version of
a website you can just do that and it
will use default mobile device metrics
so if i just do
let's see pi test my first test dash
dash mobile
that is going to go back to the sas demo
site but it's going to use the mobile
version
which as you can see it's
slightly different from before
and you'll be able to run a mobile test
not just
the regular web test just by adding the
dash dash mobile as a command line
option
and of course there's a lot more options
that you didn't get to see here
but there is a full list on the
selenium-based page on github
the dashboard looks like this so if
there's a lot of tests you can see your
failing tests uh your passing tests
uh here's what it looks like with the uh
you know some failing tests at the top
and there's
logs so that if there is a test failure
you can see what went wrong and we
didn't run any failing tests right now
but i'm just going to quickly do
pi test test suite and then dash dash
html equals report dot html and dash
dash dashboard
and dash dash rs i'm just going to do a
quick one more quick uh
suite of four like two second tests so
that you can see
what the logs look like when a test
fails
you know take screenshots and all that
and give you all the info
so here we have a dashboard.html
so if we
were to open that inside
a new window
you can see that
here it ran four tests where two failed
and two passed
and inside the data folder you'll have
things such as basic test info which
shows you the tests that you ran the
last page that it was on the browser
used the driver
and the date that it ran with my time
zone
etc
and then the stack trace
and the most important thing it will
have the screenshot right here that you
can click on it and see what went wrong
all right let me go back to the uh
chat so we have q and a
let's see we have a question from vishnu
uh in the word puzzle how is it
identifying yellow color and proceeding
further and how is it identifying green
color okay so inside the website when
you're running
wordle so i'm just going to quickly get
that back so that
we can see
a
chat window is blocking
the screen
oh there we go okay so
uh
on the website itself we're gonna
quickly i'm gonna show you how that
looks
so if we go to
wordle
it's gonna quickly jump directly to it
if you if you guessed a word such as
stuff
i think the answer was bluff and we're
gonna do enter
if we right click and inspect the
element
it'll actually tell you whether or not
it was a green tile or a
yellow tile
if you inspect it inside there
it will be in the html
so let's see
data title data state equals correct
there that is the main thing there so if
you have a word in the correct place or
a letter in the correct place it's going
to show
a data state property equals correct now
if it is in the wrong place
it'll say uh or if it's not the letter
is not there at all if i go here data
state equals absent because there is no
uh t
in
the word
so
if i were to
do
let's do blunt
where letters aren't going to be in the
correct place
you'll see that's not a good one because
uh let's do
here we go there's a yellow one so here
the u is in the incorrect place so you
can do data state equals present
and inside the html based on that you
can say okay
the word
or the letter u is not in the correct
place but it is in the word so
the css selector for that would be data
state present there
all right let's see uh let's back to q a
any more questions technical all right
well we're gonna do a quick one more
quick thing uh for the recorder so that
you can see
how the recorder works
uh let's see
i'm just trying to
there we go let's move that out of the
way if we do space recorder
it's going to start the recorder desktop
app and let's say we want to do a quick
recording so let's do sasdemo.com
and we're going to click record
it's going to go here and if i
copy
standard user in here and i copy
secret sauce in here and i do a login
and i'm going to add
three items to the cart
and then once that's set i'm going to
click on the cart item
[Music]
and i can verify that things are there
so i'm going to
uh basically i could verify that that
says it's 15.99 that's 49 and that's
that
and then i'm going to click checkout
i'm going to type
in hello
selenium
and then one two three four five
continue
and then i'm going to click finish
and i want to verify that it says thank
you for your order so i'm going to
switch into assert element mode
and then once i am done recording the
actions i can type c
and it's going to generate the recorded
uh script
so this is just one quick way where you
can use the selenium-based recorder
to generate a full script so you saw
here that i went to this website
uh
it saw that we clicked the item
and then
it generated the script so that will
allow you to quickly
uh play back the script that you just
saw so that you can quickly create tests
and if you need to generate
a new test on the fly you can use the
recorder to do that
so here you have it playing back a
recording so the selenium-based recorder
is sort of like selenium ide
except uh it's python based
uh let's see if i can answer anyone's
questions so that
uh pretty much uh covers everything uh
hi niddy how are you doing thanks for
the session michael anyone have any
questions
i didn't get to cover
uh everything but as you saw that you
can use
selenium-based and python and selenium
to solve wordle
and interact with the website easily
interact with shadow dom and you can
generate scripts easily with the
recorder and use additional command line
options so that you can see reports and
etc or demo mode so that you can see
exactly
what your test is doing and you can
easily connect to a grid server for say
browser stack saw slabs lambda test etc
our sponsors here so that you can run
your selenium based python tests on one
of their grids thanks michael for
sharing your experience with us today